When you stop and think about it, it’s a
little shocking to realize just how much impact
Disney has over the world’s youngest generations,
aiming animated films squarely at kids when
they’re at their most impressionable.
But there’s no reason to worry, right?
Disney movies tell stories in which the heroes
beat the villains, good triumphs over evil,
people accept their differences, and live
happily ever after… but those aren’t always
the lessons being taught.
And when you take a closer look, you have
to wonder if we’re sending our kids the
best possible messages.
That’s exactly what we’re doing in our
latest docu video: Why Kids Should NEVER Watch
Disney Movies.
Don’t Listen to Your Parents
The Lion King
The Little Mermaid
Finding Nemo
When you’re a kid, your parents are responsible
for most of the worst parts of life: eating
vegetables, getting grounded, and basically
telling you what NOT to do.
So is it any coincidence that most Disney
movies begin the same way, with boring, angry
or just worrying parents insisting the heroes
NOT go on an adventure, and just stay home,
away from excitement?
Kids soon learn that if they want real adventure,
new friends, or the life they truly deserve,
it all starts by completely ignoring your
parents advice or rules.
It’s actually staggering when you realize
how many Disney movies rely on this same twist
– assuming the hero has any parents left
alive.
Sure, going places your parents say are dangerous,
getting friendly with people they see as villains,
or actively putting yourself in danger all
works out in a Disney movie, but not in the
real world.
In the real world, getting kidnapped like
Nemo, cursed like the Little Mermaid, or heading
to the one place your king father told you
not to like Simba is a lesson you shouldn’t
have to learn.
It gets weirder when you realize how boys
and girls are treated differently by Disney.
While Disney princesses deal with overbearing
parents (Jasmine, Brave, Little Mermaid, Frozen),
the decision to ignore their advice usually
leads to tragedy – leaving them in need
of being rescued.
For the boys (Nemo, Prince Philip in Little
Mermaid, Simba, Tarzan), disobeying parents
leads to adventure.
It may be a rough one, but it makes them the
heroes they were meant to be, and you can’t
save the day – or the girl – unless you
ruin everything first!
Assume The Best of Absolutely Everyone
Beauty and the Beast
The Little Mermaid
Aladdin
The Lion King
Tarzan
Snow White
Teaching kids that listening to your legal
guardians means nothing but a boring life
is bad enough, but what about the strangers,
criminals, or villains they might encounter
along the way?
Disney has more solid advice: no matter how
evil, deceitful, or dangerous a person might
appear, always – always – assume they’re
your friend.
Parents and teachers might educate kids on
“stranger danger” but Disney does the
opposite.
An old woman offers you food?
It’s rude NOT to eat it (Snow White).
Your father’s older, clearly evil and creepy
friend getting a little too close?
An insult or two is all you need.
Your uncle clearly wants you and your father
dead, and doesn’t even hide it anymore?
Laugh it off!
And if all your dreams are promised to come
true by a witch or wizard who might as well
be wearing a t-shirt that says “DON’T
TRUST ME”, magic is magic (Little Mermaid).
Also, it’s unfair to assume people will
succumb to their old habits or worst qualities
when given the perfect opportunity to let
them loose (Clayton in Tarzan).
Making the villains look evil from the start
may clue kids in on the story, but when they
enter the world thinking every person who
wants to hurt, trick, or take advantage of
will literally look completely evil, how can
you expect them NOT to get fooled?
All Love is True Love If You’re Beautiful
Cinderella
Sleeping Beauty
The Little Mermaid
Aladdin
Tarzan
Frozen
Tangled
The Princess and the Frog
The Hunchback of Notre Dame
It’s what makes sure good wins over evil,
breaking curses, and turning even the hardest
of hearts pure again: true love.
Or, in Disney movies, basically anytime two
beautiful people meet – especially if one
needs to be rescued by the end of the story.
You could argue that Disney is bound to draw
people who are nice to look at, since nobody
would ever want to see even the most heroic
and good-hearted characters find love if they’re
truly, truly ugly (sorry, Quasi – from Hunchback).
But honestly, Disney’s classics don’t
even bother letting their princes and princesses
get to know eachother before assuming that
when two gorgeous people meet, that instant
attraction, and longing to spend more time
together in private… that’s as true as
love gets.
Honestly, you don’t even need to be awake
for it!
(Sleeping Beauty kiss)
Thankfully, modern writers and directors realized
how messed up this idea really was.
Movies like Tangled and the Princess and the
Frog saw true love grow from immediate hate,
but still, even the Frog Prince or the Beast
are revealed to be incredibly handsome, and
therefore deserving of that love in the end.
The abusive insults was all just emotional
armor!
Frozen even played on this classic Disney
trope, since Anna falls in love with the first
man she meets – and it was all part of his
evil plan.
Thankfully, she DOES fall in love by the end
of the movie, meaning THIS (Kristoff from
Frozen) is about as ugly a man as a Disney
princess is allowed to fall for.
And only when the alternative is literally
trying to murder you.
It’s Good to Be Different…
Eventually
Wreck-it Ralph
Brave
Frozen
The Incredibles
Finding Nemo
Dumbo
Monsters, Inc.
It’s impossible to count how many Disney
movies begin the same way: with a hero or
heroine who is a little bit different, getting
them teased until they reach their true potential,
and show that being different is what makes
them special.
A great message until you realize that Disney
is basically claiming that our differences
should be, could be, or simply ARE ridiculed,
no matter the difference.
Sure, everyone gets along in the end, but
only after the person with the deformity (Finding
Nemo, Dumbo), less-than-desirable role as
the bad guy (Wreck-it Ralph, Sully from Monsters,
Inc.), or just a free spirit (Brave) proves
that they are actually exceptional, and their
problem is really a gift.
But what if it ISN’T?
For starters, we would argue that Disney movies
showing young characters who aren’t being
tormented or ostracized by parents or friends
for their differences would probably be a
better message for kids to receive.
Frozen is the biggest movie from Disney in
years, and it told kids that even if they
are literally magical witches or wizards,
they should probably hide that, because everyone
will be terrified of you showing what makes
you special.
And yes, the movie ends with Elsa’s powers
accepted, and the sisters reconnecting – but
only after they were almost murdered., and
everyone agreeing to be cool with ice powers
if they got winter in July.
What if the villain’s plan DIDN’T require
Elsa be killed, and just let her be run out
of her kingdom?
And what if Dumbo’s giant ears DIDN’T
allow him to fly?
Would nobody have actually gotten past it?
If only Quasimoto’s hunchback granted wishes.
In the end, it might be the biggest lesson
Disney movies teach to kids: the things that
make you different will cause most people
to hate you.
But only until they see it’s what makes
you special.
Like, actually special, like have a superpower.
Otherwise….
We hope you like gargoyles (last Quasimoto
shot, I swear).
So what do you think?
Are the lessons taught by Disney movies more
complicated, or more messed up than they usually
claim?
Are there any other prime examples we’re
missing?
There’s no right answer, but it’s hard
to ignore that the kind of ‘adult’ messages
or tone Disney is tackling require closer
attention than they’re being given.
Let us know what you think, and remember to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.